hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my arrow episode 3 SummerSlam rematch
video careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen it yet but it's basically
like the thing that inspired this
t-shirt that I wear all the time so here
we go so it's a pretty solid episode it
was really you know like the fun part
was the SummerSlam rematch Cody Rhodes
for Stephen Amell Stephen Amell was
going crazy with all the wrestling stuff
that they got to put into this like all
the real life stuff that happened
between them between meeting Cody Rhodes
in sort of like the rivalry they
developed in how that culminated in
SummerSlam so that was really only part
of the episode but you know then you
have the Deadshot WTF so I'll explain
that a whole bunch of comic book stuff
so top 10 WTF and Easter eggs here we go
number 10 Cody Rhodes is Samson on arrow
he's part of the arrow verse now and
they didn't kill him at the end of the
episode so he's recovering somewhere in
a hospital prison but Samson isn't quite
the same as Samson the actual comic book
character so I think he's just an
original character they created for this
show and Stephen Amell said he did like
an amazing job behind the scenes Cody
Rhodes did so they'll probably try to
have him back if they can't if you're a
big wrestling fan I don't know if Cody
is using this to stage a big comeback in
the WWE because he quit being Stardust
but like that's the number nine the drug
that he's manufacturing and selling is
called Stardust it's supposed to be ten
times worse than vertigo but I guess it
makes you super chill because that's
what like the one thug tells Oliver
sounds like you need some man you need
to chill but number eight Cody takes a
bath in the Stardust mixture Joker style
gets himself a full-blown comic book
origin story so number seven next new
character on the list Susan Williams
who's a reporter for channel 52 they're
actually like doing something with
channel 52 it's not just background
noise anymore so she is a character from
the Green Lantern comics she was married
to Hal Jordans brother in the comics and
they had a child together there was a
long period where she was obsessed with
outing him as Green Lantern but then she
learned that it was actually Hal Jordan
so they might be doing that on arrow
where she tries to figure Green Arrow
things out but I don't think they're
allowed to say Hal Jordans name but
expect some Green Lantern Easter eggs
across the season with her character but
we met her
she'll get some scenes with all of her
eventually you can see already that
she's not a super nice person but we'll
see if she has any chemistry with all of
her I don't know they might have some
fun with that but number six meet Adrian
chase another new character who is the
new District Attorney
he's a comic book character his name is
get this vigilante he was created by
Marv Wolfman there was actually like an
image of him in that first episode when
they were doing mug shots this is what
his comic book character looks like in
the picture was actually drawn brand-new
by Marv Wolfman so that they could use
it in the episode but Marc Guggenheim
did say that they were taking him in a
very comic book II direction like
they're assuming that people read the
comics when it comes to his character
storyline in they're rolling hard on it
in episode 7 but the interesting thing
about that is that he did not say that
they're turning him into vigilante
because the way Adrian chase in the
episode explains it
he and Oliver have history together
going back at least 12 years all of her
[ __ ] blocked him and took one of his
girlfriends so it sounds like he didn't
like Oliver very much so whatever their
relationship is going to be it's gonna
be pretty interesting but part of me
felt like they were teasing some
Prometheus stuff like Prometheus has
history with Oliver going back to season
one
Adrian chase has history with Oliver
going way way back in in Prometheus as
beef with green arrow makes it sound
like Prometheus knows that Oliver is the
green arrow so they're just a couple
people that make that list like Tommy's
on the list and while I'm not convinced
that Adrian chase could be prometheus
I'm just gonna be watching their scenes
together in the dialogue that they have
very closely but in the comics just to
explain what happens to the vigilante
character so he is the district attorney
in the comics who becomes a vigilante
because he feels like the law isn't
helping him take down criminals fast
enough like he sees criminals using the
law to get off scot-free
the court system can't help him so he
becomes a vigilante to take care of them
at night but eventually he goes off the
rails crazy and becomes kind of a
villain so that's kind of why I felt
like he would be one of the antagonists
this season but that doesn't guarantee
that he'll turn into Prometheus it just
means
then he and Oliver will probably be
throwing down eventually but number five
belissa T comes clean to Ragman about
being the person responsible for his
home his family died so he just can't
handle it he walks up obviously they're
gonna deal with it next week's episode
but this guilt is part of Felicity's arc
they explain this season like dealing
with this this first part of the season
then eventually it'll spin into
something else they haven't really said
but it's like a character-based arc so I
don't know how Comic Book II it's going
to get in the back half but I always
felt like a fun art for Felicity would
be you know like she loves her team like
her family hears so much that she would
go way overboard and do like a Tony
Stark Ultron type thing where she
creates something to try and help them
but it goes way sideways and becomes
this big big problem but number four
speaking of blowing up in your face Cody
Rhodes verse Stephen Amell round two
they were really like two big fights
between them in this episode there was
the first one where Oliver tries to take
him down in the hospital the second big
one my number three was actually a
pretty good wrestling match if you're a
big fan of wrestling you might notice
some choke holds even someone like the
way they punched each other like the
stunts were engineered that Cody had
felt very much like the kind of stuff
that you would see in a wrestling match
so they did a lot of slow-mo like the
way they filmed it was a little bit
different Stephen Amell said like behind
the scenes they got really excited like
they tried to do things in a way that
they had not done them before so there's
a lot more slow motion stuff like this
this season but I did like the logic
behind the takedown you might not be
able to feel your tendons being sliced
but that doesn't mean that you don't
need them so it kind of winds up being
like this Deadpool vs. Colossus fight
where Deadpool just like smashes all of
his limbs trying to fight Colossus just
flopping around like a Tyrannosaurus Rex
all the dinosaurs were afraid of the
t-rex but number three Brava initiation
the episode was all about trusting your
team even if that wasn't necessarily a
good thing or didn't seem like a good
thing that was the whole message of the
flashbacks the Bratva are very bad
people but Oliver needs them to take on
Kovar and then like you kind of learned
through like the side mission that they
go on that they actually do give justice
to people who can't get it through
traditional means so it's not all bad
even though it's still pretty shade
but I felt like the joke of this is the
like they'll slice them up and then just
like douse him in lemonade just like
just thousands of really deep paper cuts
and then just throw them in a lemonade
bath let's just see how much terrible
fraternity initiation stuff that we can
make Oliver go through but as you can
see now that he is part of the Bratva
they can get onto the Kovar stuff the
whole point of this is in him gaining
this Brotherhood to take Coe far on they
can make a beeline for Ivan Drago and
have their like he-man rocky for fight
number two of course do you guys
probably sense that I was building to
this Deadshot is back or is he everybody
like during the episode when he first
appeared everyone's like oh my god this
is so amazing how did this happen is it
flashpoint what's the deal so then later
when we learned that Diggle just
hallucinatin him he's tripping balls in
prison Deadshot is still dead
you know big bummer so it was like the
whole spectrum of Suicide Squad Deadshot
in this episode the way Marc Guggenheim
explained it afterwards is that comic
book characters in general are a
case-by-case basis especially characters
that are in the movies right now so what
happens is when they want to use a
Suicide Squad character they have to
pitch DC and in this case it just
happened to be geoff johns who like saw
the pitch and was like okay great so
hand to god geoff johns is like you are
approved use your Deadshot sir so many
thanks to geoff johns and number one of
course is like the mr. terrific
backstory like they did a hardcore
accurate comic-book backstory fair play
Terry Sloan he wears the face paint and
obviously like this is Curtis Holt
instead of Michael Holt because the
mister terrific of the comics is more
like Diggle he's a giant dude with huge
muscles so that's probably why they went
with the Curtis name but next week even
more comic book characters Artemis is
gonna start using a bow so by the end of
the season we might see her in a comic
book accurate costume but let me know in
the comments what were you guys favorite
thing from the episode like what do you
think is gonna happen with Adrian chase
and do you think we'll ever see
hallucination Deadshot again he is still
alive on earth - because flashpoint
didn't affect her - so he's still like
the bumbling police captain but I'm not
expecting him back any time soon but it
is fun how they're able to do characters
you normally think
they would not be able to do they said
that they did that for the hundredth
episode anybody that they could use had
access to is gonna be in that episode
it's episode eight even characters that
weren't available because of scheduling
conflicts which when he said that I
think Marc Guggenheim was talking about
Deathstroke because we saw the pictures
of Deathstroke that Stephen Amell was
posting and Manu Bennett works on like
so many other series that his
availability is really spotty
so they wanted to use them in the
episode as Deathstroke so we get
Deathstroke but there's like a slight
workaround so expect that for some other
big arrow characters in the hundredth
episode but on all great episode and
obviously there's a bunch more DC stuff
happening tonight because we have
Justice Society so because so much stuff
is happening that video might end up
posting tomorrow but I'll get it out as
fast as possible but it's like a
full-blown Justice Society episode so
we'll explain all the characters when I
post that be sure to subscribe to get
that video there's a round of the DC
giveaway that's going on right now all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so next videos will be like cool
Doctor Strange stuff that's happening
Kevin Feige confirmed a whole bunch of
stuff about Illuminati so I'll do a
Doctor Strange Illuminati Avengers
infinity war video I'll do just a
society that I'll do some new guardians
of the galaxy 2 slightly new outro while
you guys wait for my next video to post
you can click up top for that Logan red
band trailer again and you can click
down here for this week's episode of the
flash thank you so much for watching
everybody let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight